hey guys so back in winter we told you
guys we would give you a rundown on what
makes a scarlet a special camera so
finally uh seven months afterwards
we've gotten around to doing so so the
scarlet is the uh the very first really
professional camera that we've owned
it's kind of like a professional
filmmaker's dream come true for us
because it's a true cinematic camera we
could go out and shoot something with
this
that is of the quality that you can go
into the theaters and see and don't get
me wrong like the 7d is great camera the
sony fs100 like all those cameras
great cameras but generally speaking you
couldn't go to a theater um and shoot
with one of those and have it be in the
cinema all right so one of the most
notable things about the red camera is
that it shoots raw now some of you
photographers out there you know are
familiar with the format but most of you
guys shoot video so the way your camera
works is you have a digital sensor light
comes in hits at sensor that sensor
turns that light into electrical ones
and zeros sends them off to your
camera's processor your camera takes
those signals and turns them into an
image and now what you finally get on
your little memory card at the end of
the day is that finished image encoded
as h.264 mpeg2 whatever the format is
that your camera is shooting in now what
that also means all the things are
happening after the light hits the
sensor
that's all baked in for good you can't
go back and change that but when you're
shooting in raw with this camera you can
go back you can change things like your
white balance you can go change your iso
after the fact you can go change your
saturation your color balance basically
anything that is done after the light
hits the sensor the only things
that you can't adjust are the things
from before the light hits the sensor
are you in focus your shutter speed your
aperture
those three things are basically the
only things you have to worry about with
this camera it makes things much quicker
and easier to shoot you're rolling
running in a car and a cloud goes with
the sun and suddenly the temperature
changes of the light you don't have to
worry about it you can fix it later so
for us that's a big thing so we got a
small crew and we run a gun so another
special thing about this camera is that
it shoots in 4k resolution now what is a
k 4k 2k what does that all mean
basically a k is the horizontal
resolution your image for example 1080p
is roughly 2k it's 1920 pixels aka 1.9 k
or 2k if you round up this camera shoots
4k generally most of the stuff we shoot
is at a resolution of 3840
by 2160 so you got a lot of pixels to
play with that means if we need to
stabilize the shot afterwards and it's
cropped in order to pull a close-up from
a medium shot we can do it with this
camera and you guys can't really notice
the difference on youtube because they
have so much extra resolution to play
with
everything looks better downscaled and
this camera gives us a chance to do that
so 4k resolution we thought we would
never use it but guess what it's super
convenient
so one of the things that we as
filmmakers and probably all you guys on
the internet have sought after for all
these years is the film look what is the
film look at first everybody thought
that was 24 frames per second so all the
cameras got 24 frames per second and
that helped but that wasn't the film
look shallow depth of field lenses that
went a long ways and now you have things
like dslrs that let you shoot video with
those nice lenses in the big format
sensors that gives you that really
cinematic shallow depth of field and
that's close but that's still not the
film look the film look
comes from high dynamic range what is
that
well basically your camera
the sensor on your camera has a range of
light that it can take in there's a
certain point where the light gets too
dark and it goes to black basically it
turns into noise you can boost it but
you're just gonna get snow
and then you have another point at which
the sensor clips when it gets too much
light and you just get white so the
range between the part where your sensor
clips and when it's just black noise
that's your dynamic range some cameras
like your iphone only have a couple
stops of dynamic range if you go outside
you take a picture in the sunlight
the shadow side of your face is going to
be black while the sunny side is exposed
or if you expose the shadow side the
sunny sides can be blown out white but
if you use a better camera you can
actually see the detail in the shadow
and you can see the detail on the bright
part so for example this camera if i
film a shot here looking out the garage
i can actually get all these stuff
outside of the garage in direct sunlight
to expose without clipping and i can get
the stuff inside the garage to expose
without descending into noise he tried
to do it with another camera like an
iphone or even the fs100 you can't get
the same amount of range now the thing
is your eyes as a human being have way
more stops and dynamic range than any
camera so the more a camera can mimic
that the more vibrant and alive and
painterly an image becomes so another
thing that makes this camera exceptional
is that it's built to be modular you
might notice the camera body itself is
essentially just a box and we have a
bunch of things added onto it got a
battery plate back here for putting
bigger batteries on it i got handles
that i've added to the top that are
bolted into the top
i've got a side handle that bolts onto
the side and of course i have a lens on
the front you can actually take all this
stuff off and rearrange it however you
want rather than the camera according to
a cf card or sd card it actually records
to solid-state drives known as a red meg
basically it's just a solid-state drive
inside of this a little expensive but
they're also very fast and very durable
so you can offload 64 gigabytes of
footage in like 10 minutes shooting
gigantic 4k file sizes raw
how big of a file are you dealing with
at the end of the day
relatively speaking the files are about
one and a half to 1.2 gigs per minute
which is not too bad actually every
video since footloose you have shot with
a scarlet including footloose there's
something cathartic in making a video as
widely downvoted and ridiculous as
footloose and shooting that on a red
camera
but yeah basically uh tether um art of
the insta kill
uh photo reel footloose etc we're all
shot with this camera we have a workflow
figured out that actually works really
well a lot of people actually
wonder how you can work with these new
files and keep it as fast as you need to
be when you're on youtube it actually
works great for us we turn it around
just as fast as would in any other case
also some of you guys are probably
saying
well i don't have a scarlet how can i
make my stuff look good or i don't need
a scarlet my stuff looks great you're
right you don't need a scarlet you can
make your stuff look great the whole
point with this camera is that it makes
your life easier it makes it easier to
get a pretty image it's not to say you
can't get a pretty image with another
camera it's a great tool it can handle
things in a way that makes it so we can
shoot faster we can shoot quicker and
get a better looking result with less
work that's the value of this camera we
would not be able to have this camera
without you guys support thank you very
much for watching our videos and sharing
it and all that kind of stuff it has
helped us achieve our cinematic dream of
being filmmakers with big boy filmmaker
tools so
thanks guys and uh
enjoy watching the videos
you